nicolas hulot laisse planer le doute sur
ses intentions pour la présidentielle de
2007 mais le médiatique défenseurs de
l'écologie fait des propositions très
concrètes aux différents candidats et
les supplie je cite de dire la vérité
aux français sur ce qui concerne les
désordres écologiques que vit notre
planète aujourd'hui il présentait ce
matin son pacte
bagnell sportiello laurent fabius un pro
de la télé nicolas hulot je coupe le
micro à ce que qui ne se laisse pas
piéger en conférence de presse
l'animateur producteur d'ushuaïa ne dira
pas maintenant qu'il fait de la
politique
s'il veut être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle j'ai comme vous le savez
au début du mois d'août probablement
d'un accès d'impatience ou d'inquiétude
posé sur un coin de d'une table
l'hypothèse d'une candidature
personnelle simplement pour mettre à
l'aise toutes les personnes qui ont bien
voulu être présent aujourd'hui ce n'est
ni lieu ni le lieu ni l'heure de lever
cette hypothèse ou de la confirmer
mystérieuse sur ses intentions
nicolas hulot veut peser dans le débat
de la campagne entouré de stars du
cinéma de la chanson et de scientifiques
de renom il lance un pacte écologique à
l'intention des candidats à l'elysée ces
propositions
taxer les pollueurs et créer un poste de
vice premier ministre chargé du
développement durable
laurent fabius a déjà dit banco
dominique voynet l'apprécient même si
nicolas hulot peut devenir un concurrent
je ne me sens pas menacé par sa
candidature un grand ministère de
l'environnement
une politique qui voit loin et qui
anticipe sur l'évolution du monde grâce
à un vice-premier ministre développement
durable voilà quelques-unes des mesures
qui seront nécessaires nicolas hulot
vous voit très bien dans ce poste ça
fait 20 ans que les verts se prépare
franchement je crois que l'un des nôtres
sera parfaitement à sa place à ce poste
à droite on est sceptique sur une
candidature de nicolas hulot
nicolas hulot tient beaucoup à sa
liberté il n'aime pas nécessairement les
affrontements très brutaux
il n'aime pas nécessairement la
recherche de compromis sur des
politiques publiques et connaissez mon
centre udc pas par hasard qu'il avait
refusé d'être ministre de
l'environnement je suis pas sûr qu'au
fond de lui en ai vraiment envie tout
simplement difficile de combattre le
trop populaire nicolas hulot accueilli à
bras ouverts aux universités d'été
selon un sondage ifop il est pour 66%
des français celui qui représente le
mieux l'environnement pour la
présidentielle
[Musique]